When I first moved to Minneapolis, everything in my life went horribly wrong.
I transferred to a small art school.
And my girlfriend wrecked my car. Said girlfriend became an ex-girlfriend.
And the house I was living in was condemned. I was working for minimum wage in a comic
book store during the day. And going to my night classes at art school. It was not a high
point in my life.
But the only thing that kept me going was the thought of spring break.
Just one week, back home with my parents and friends, and away from this life. And
I've been saving. I'd been saving for six months but this trip. Because when you make minimum wage, saving
for anything takes a really long time.
And so I finished my last final at school and I went home and celebrated my new bachelorhood by
ordering a Domino's Pizza.
Eating it off napkins and playing video games all night. And two days
later I was
packed and I was ready to go home. All I had to do was drop my last paycheck off at the bank.
And I went into the bank and I handed the teller my check. And I got the receipt and I flipped it over and
on the back my account balance was negative five hundred thirty six
dollars. And I felt all the life
just drain out of me because I just, I couldn't catch a break.
And so I asked to see my balance statement,
and there they were, two six hundred dollar Western Union money transfers,
a bunch of random delivery orders, and a four hundred dollar charge to a website called
InmateCanteen.com
com [crowd laughs]
And so, so I sat down with the banker and she saw that the charges were false and went about trying to reverse them.
And while she was doing that I went and I sat in the lobby and I started thinking about
how unfair identity theft is.
identity theft is. Because when somebody steals your identity they only take
the good parts,
you know? They
[crowd laughs and applaudes] don't
take the rattrap apartment and the depression and the shitty
job. No, they just take the
one thing that I had been looking forward to for the past six months. And while
And while I'm mulling this over. The banker comes back and she tells me that the bank is going to give me all my
money back. But it's going to take about a week of processing.
processing. And so I go home, and I
can't get it out of my head. Because the bank wasn't going to do anything about this,
and the police weren't going to do anything about this, and these people that
rob you...they don't get caught. Nobody
cares enough. But this identity theft was different
because this person had messed with the most dangerous type of person that exists, which is
someone with limited options and a lot of free time.
And
And so I decided to start my own investigation. And so I took my bank records and
I started going through them and I called Western Union
Union. And they were no help. And I went to inmatecanteen.com
com
and I called the support number but it was disconnected.
And so all I had were these delivery charges and I noticed something,
which is that they were, they were local. And then it hit me.
The last charge that I had made on my own account was the last night of my finals. The night that
I ordered that Domino's Pizza and I realized that when I read my credit card number over the phone the
woman at Dominoes must have written it down and used it again. The woman at
Domino's robbed
me! And this was this was more upsetting,
because this was someone that could live six blocks from me, who spoke to me on the phone and
heard my voice. Someone who I trusted. I
mean. I trusted
Domino's. Out of all the people and things in my life that could betray
me Domino's was not on the list!
And lastly
because I spent years as a delivery driver and this broke
the code of ethics.
So this wasn't just a theft, this felt personal. And so I had a suspect,
and the next day I marched into that Domino's and I demanded to know who was working the night my identity was stolen.
And the manager on duty passed me to his manager who passed me to his manager. And eventually they told me to come
back later and they would have the names for me.
So I continued my investigation and I went to a place called the Green Mill which was a restaurant where some of
some of the false delivery charges had taken
place. And the manager there was really helpful because there was nothing else to do,
and he gave me a week's worth of delivery tickets, and I started digging through them looking for a match.
And after about thirty minutes the phone rang and he picked it up and start taking down an order. And he picks up a
piece of paper inserts waving it back and forth and I come over and on the paper is a credit card number,
and it's my credit card number, and the person who stole my credit card is on the other end of that
phone and the manager is looking at me like "well what do we do now?!"
And
I look him straight in the eyes and I say "give me a topper, a hat and I will take that
delivery!"
[cheering and applause]
And he looks at me and he says
"and that will get me fired". And I say OK maybe that wasn't the best idea.
Tell them
them that your driver is out sick and that it's pick up only.
And so he does and he hangs up and he looks at me and he says "they'll be here in 15 minutes".
And so I grab a newspaper
and I sit down in a booth and I
prop it up.
And I sit down for my very first stakeout. And
an agonizing seventeen minutes
later. A car pulls in, a woman gets out and comes inside and asked for her pick
up order. And I start writing down every detail.
The fact that it's a white lifted Chevy Tahoe. The license plate number. What she's wearing and what
she looks like. And meanwhile she's having a conversation with the manager and he's saying that the card was
declined and he needs to run it again. But she says she doesn't have it on her and it's in her car
and she
leaves the restaurant and doesn't come back. And so I asked the manager to do me one more favor,
I asked him to *69 the number
69 the number she called from, and I had that cellphone number to my growing list of evidence.
A couple hours later I receive a call from a man who introduces himself as the head of Domino's
And he was calling to
apologize, to thank me for my help in the investigation and to know that once I filed a
police report that Domino's had my back. He'd also
pulled the hours I wanted and had them waiting at the original Domino's
shop. So I went back and I picked them up and I started asking questions there.
And I asked if anyone there drove a white lifted Chevy Tahoe. And
the daytime driver said that a girl who worked the night shift did. A girl who matched the description
of the person who came into the Green Mill. Who was also working the night that my identity was stolen.
Lastly I took the cell phone number and gave it to the manager. Because I didn't want to call myself and arouse suspicion,
so he called it and she answered and confirmed her identity,
damning herself. So next
I asked to see her application, because those places always keep those things on file. And at
first the manager was wary of the legal things with
that, but once I assured him that this was for the police
report...he
relented. And so after I've copied down this information now
I have her first, middle and last name, her date of birth, her social security number,
her driver's license number. I know her car make and model and the license plate number. I know where
and when she works and where
she lives and her previous job references. And her email address.
And so I go home and I just...I'm in a frenzy and I can't stop.
And so I google her e-mail address and when you do that you can pull up all of the
accounts that you've created with that e-mail
address. And so I found her E-bay account, and her Flickr account, and her My Space.
And her My Space was set to public and I can see her pictures and her comments and her blogs and I
realize that I am going
crazy. [crowd laughs]
But the thing about going crazy is you
can't stop. And so I open one of
her blogs called fifty things about me.
And the very first question is what is my favorite food. And she wrote...
pizza. And so by the time I'm at the end of this list
I realize that I know more about this
woman probably than most of her coworkers and friends. And that
this is a real person that I will
be sending to jail. But she broke the
code. And so I call the cops.
And the next day they send out a police officer to take my report. And the fraud report starts out normal,
it's just how much money was stolen and when was it stolen is a bank reimbursing you. And then the
last question almost as an afterthought was "do you have any additional information which might benefit
the case?"
And I said "why, yes I do." And I start listing things.
things. And the confusion on the officers face turns to laughter when she hears the full story
and she says that "well, you've done my job for me."
me". And I agree.
Later on that day I receive a call from the detective now working this case. He says that with all my
information he cross checked it with the DOT records in the criminal database and that all checks out,
and that by the end of the day there would be a warrant out for this woman's arrest.
I tell him that she's going to work tomorrow at Domino's at five.
[laughter and clapping]
And after a pause he says that he'll have a squad car waiting for
her.
And so lastly I asked the detective
if I can be there.
Because I've done a lot of work on this! And
I kind of wanted to
see the look on her face. That same look of shock and horror that I had when I
was sitting in that bank and I flipped that receipt over and saw
everything I had saved gone. But he said that was impossible.
He did
say that if I happen to be walking across the street at around five o'clock
that no one would probably be the wiser.
So I gotta go undercover one last time. And I found myself standing
across the street from that Domino's at five o'clock squad car parked in back in two officers inside.
And I saw that white lifted Chevy Tahoe come around the corner, and park, and her get out and go
through the front door and I could see her back arched up...she froze and saw the
officers because she knew she was caught.
And then they handcuffed her, put her in the back of the squad car and they drove away. Case closed.
But then a couple hours later I received one of the most surreal phone calls I've ever gotten my entire life.
The man on the other end of the
line introduced himself as the C.E.O. of Domino's. He was calling to
personally apologize, thanked me for my help in the investigation, and I assume
avoid a
giant lawsuit. And so he asked me how much money was
stolen and told me that Domino's would reimburse me for everything, and I told him that the bank was already doing
that and that it wasn't about the money. And so he asked me what I wanted.
And up until this point I hadn't really thought about it, but what do you say I mean, free pizza for
life? A pizza named after me?
I'd lost my taste for pizza at this point.
No, I told him I didn't want this to happen to anyone else. I told him that I wanted him
to pursue this to the furthest extent of
the law and that every new Domino's employee that gets hired would hear this story... that if
if you f*** with credit card information of customers that you will go to
jail. And he said he could do that. [laughter]
And
later I received two letters in the mail.
The first was a letter that said the woman had pleaded guilty to all charges and will
be serving a short prison sentence. The second a personal
thank you letter from the C.E.O. of
Domino's, a check for the exact amount of money stolen, and five hundred Domino's
bucks. [laughter]
And I realize that I actually did get everything back that was stolen.
The money,
yes, but for that week I wasn't the pathetic
depressed art student. No! for that
week I was Tristen Jimerson...Private
Eye. [laughter]
The gum-shoe that
knows that revenge, like delivery pizza, is best served cold.
Thank you.
[applause and cheering]